hey everyone welcome to this new video
by simply load in this video we will
cover top 10 highest paying AIML jobs we
will start by knowing top five AI
highest paying AI jobs followed by top
five highest paying ml jobs so without
any further delay over to our tutors AI
is changing the world a lot it's like
having helpful friends on our devices
like Siri and Alexa who can understand
us really well also AI is like a secret
helper in the internet World suggesting
things we might like when we watch shows
or shop online but it's not just about
making life easy AI is doing big things
too for example in healthcare it's
finding new medicines faster and helping
doctors spot problems early a is also
good for the planet because it helps us
save energy and predict the weather more
accurately the future looks even better
with AI making a world more innovative
and efficient at the same time it's like
a kind of a magic the more magical thing
about this field is the salary this
field offers to the professionals it's
mind-blowing and fascinating a Gartner
study reports that AI is an emerging
field that will create 2.8 million jobs
by 2025 so this video will discuss the
top five AI jobs in 2024 with highest
salaries this video will help you in
getting the answer to one of the most
sought-after questions related to
artificial intelligence why you should
consider a in this exponentially growing
field but before we begin if you enjoy
watching these videos and find them
interesting then subscribe to our
YouTube channel because we bring the
best videos for you daily also press the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply certifications provide the most
significant and well- defined part to
mastering any field on that note you can
also accelerate your career in Ai and
machine learning with our comprehensive
post-graduate program in Ai and machine
learning boost your career with this Ai
and machine learning course delivered in
collaboration with the per University
and IB learn in demand skills such as
machine learning deep learning NLP
computer vision reinforcement learning
generative AI prompt engineering chat
GPT and Manu you will receive a
prestigious certificate and ask me
anything sessions by IBM with five
capstones and different domains using
real data sets you will gain practical
experience master classes by PD faculty
and IBM experts ensure top-notch
education simply learns job assist helps
you get noticed by the leading companies
this program covers statistics python
supervised and unsupervised learning NLP
neural networks computer vision Gan
caras tensorflow and many more such
skills admission to this postgraduate
program in Ai and machine learning
requires two plus years of work
experience a bachelor's degree with an
average of 50% or higher marks basic
understanding of programming Concepts
and Mathematics so enroll now and unlock
exciting Ai and machine learning
opportunities the link is mentioned in
the description box below so without any
further delay let's start this video
with what is artificial intelligence
artificial intelligence refers to the
development of computer systems and
software that can perform tasks that
typically require human intelligence
these tasks include reasoning problem
solving learning from experience
understanding natural language
recognizing patterns and making
decisions AI aims to create machines or
softwares that can mimic human cognitive
functions enabling them to perform tasks
with worrying level of complexity AI is
surely one of the most sought-after
Industries for professionals looking for
a promising career and a lucrative
salary so let's talk about the top five
AI jobs with the highest salaries at
number five we have a computer vision
engineer a computer vision engineer is a
programmer skilled in creating software
using visual input sensors and
algorithms these systems can interpret
their environment as seen in
self-driving cars and facial recognition
computer vision engine Engineers uses
languages like C++ and python they work
on tasks like object detection image
segmentation facial and gesture
recognition and scene comprehension
consequently the compensation packages
for computer vision Engineers have
become notably attractive according to
glaso the average salary of a computer
vision engineer is
$155,000 in the United States and in
India it's rupees 8 lakh perom serving
as a significant incentive for
individual venturing into this domain at
number four we have software Engineers
software Engineers handle tasks from
design to deployment but it's rare to
find experts in All Phases they usually
specializes in specific areas this
specialization applies to AI software
Engineers too they work on various
applications including machine learning
inference learning NLP and intrusion
detection covering different aspects of
AI development consequently the
compensation pack packages for software
Engineers have become notably attractive
according to glaso the average salary of
a software engineer is
$14,000 in the United States and in
India it's rupees 9 lakh perom serving
as a significant incentive for
individuals venturing into this domain
moving on to number three we have
machine learning Engineers a machine
learning engineer creates and deploys
training algorithms and models which is
the most demanding part of machine
learning most machine learning engineers
hold Advanced degrees in computer
science mathematics or statistics due to
the need for advanced math skills many
also pursue specialized master's degrees
or certifications in machine learning
deep learning or neural networks
consequently the compensation packages
for ML Engineers as well is notably
attractive according to glasso the
average salary of a machine learning
engineer is
$150,000 in the United States and in
India it goes up to 11 lakh rupees perom
with additional cash benefits at number
two we have an AI research scientist AI
research scientists often computer
scientists focuses on innovating AI
algorithms and models their duties
include creating and evaluating new AI
models collaborating in research
publishing papers and presenting at
conferences while programming is a part
of their work it's just a portion unlike
the tech industry's openness to
self-taught programmers AI research
scientists need strong backgrounds in
Compu computer science mathematics and
statistics consequently the compensation
packages for AI research scientists have
become notably attractive according to
glaso the average salary of an AI
research scientist is
$125,000 in the United States and rupees
21 lakhs perom in India with additional
cash benefits and finally at number one
we have an AI product manager an AI
product manager is much like other
program managers they oversee teams for
AI product development handling
schedules and Milestones to do this
effectively they need to understand AI
components like hardware and programming
languages which helps them support their
teams creating AI apps differs from web
applications in structure and
development processes consequently the
compensation is the highest for AI
product managers in 2024 according to
glaso the average salary of an AI
product manager is
$190,000 in the United States and in IND
it goes around 26 lakh rupees perom with
additional cash compensations so these
are the top five job roles you should
consider entering in 2024 so let's go
through the reasons why AI individuals
are paid so much the first reason is
surging demand AI is in high demand
across Industries due to its potential
for Innovation and competitiveness
leading to higher salaries for
Professionals in this field specialized
expertise a specialist possesses unique
skills in in areas like machine learning
and data analysis justifying their
higher pay business impact ai's
transformative potential for businesses
results in higher compensation for
experts who help Implement AI Solutions
Talent scarcity the shortage of
qualified AI professionals creates
intense competition among employers
driving up salaries and the last reason
is continuous learning and Innovation AI
experts are rewarded for staying updated
and Innovative in a rapidly evolving
field with the growing demand for AI
expertise skilled professionals have
opportunities to boost their earnings by
enhancing their skills acquiring
Advanced education and gaining practical
experience so let's dive into four
effective strategies to elevate your AI
engineer salary enabling you to excel in
a competitive job market and negotiate
more favorable compensation the first
strategy is broaden your skill set
continuously expand your expertise in AI
related domains such as machine learning
deep learning natural language
processing and of course computer vision
stay up to date with the latest tools
Frameworks and algorithms by becoming an
expert in specific areas due to
exceptional Knowledge and Skills you can
command higher compensation pursue
Advanced education consider pursuing
Advanced degrees in AI or related fields
such as a master's or a post-graduate
course higher levels of Education often
opens doors to higher paying career
opportunities Advance degrees not only
showcase your commitment to the field
but also provide you with an extensive
knowledge and research experience
experience significantly boosting your
earning potential gain practical
experience engage in real world AI
projects to accumulate practical
experience and build a robust portfolio
explore options such as internships
contributions to open source projects
and involvement in AI research
initiatives and the last strategy is
pursue industry recognized
certifications attain certifications
that are widely recognized in artificial
intelligence technology and framework
domain these certifications validate
your AI skills and competence
positioning you as a valuable asset for
companies adopting AI Solutions such
credentials gives you competitive Adge
over other candidates and result in more
generous salary offers on that note do
check out the link mentioned in the
description below for postgraduate
program in Ai and machine learning by
perd University and simply learn the job
opportunities in machine learning are as
wide- ranging and abundant as the
technology applications from
self-driving cars to online shopping
speech recognition and face recognition
there's virtually no significant area of
Modern Life that hasn't experienced a
transformation due to the work of
machine learning Engineers who build
them if you're aiming to work in the
field that offers impressive pay and
benefits along with excellent job
satisfaction machine learning is for you
moving forward we'll cover some top
machine learning jobs showing upward
machine learning salary Trends the list
covers machine learning salaries by job
rooll and geography on that note if
you're an aspiring AIML engineer there's
no better time to train yourself in the
exciting field of machine learning if
you're looking for a course that covers
everything from the fundamentals to
Advanced Techniques like machine
learning algorithm development and un
supervised learning look no further than
our celtech in partnership with IBM this
Ai and machine learning boot camp in
collaboration with ctech will help you
advance your career as an AI nml
specialist this a ml boot camp includes
live classes delivered by industry
experts Hands-On Labs industry relevant
projects and master classes by celtech
professors key features of this amazing
machine learning course includes that is
earn up to 22 cus from Kelch ctme the
next is online convocation by keltech
ctme program director then we have
simply learn career services that help
you get noticed by top hiring companies
and you will earn a boot camp
certificate from the ctech ctme and the
industry relevant Capstone projects in
three domains celex ctm is circle
membership 25 plus Hands-On projects
across industry verticals with
integrated Labs so why wait join now
seats are filling fast find the course
link mentioned in the description box
and pin command so without any further
Ado let's get started so number one on
the list is AI research scientist AI
research scientist dedicates their
efforts to creating Innovative models
and algorithms within the realm of
machine learning
their work involves pioneering research
and exploring emerging Concepts and
Technologies this role Demands a strong
grasp of mathematics statistics and
computer science along with Proficiency
in programming languages like python or
R exceptional problem solving abilities
are also crucial AI research scientists
typically command an average yearly
salary of $91,000 in the United States
and in India an average annual yearly
salary is around 9 lakhs per anom moving
forward let's see who wants more than AI
research scientist and now number two on
the list is NLP engineer a natural
language processing engineer is a
professional responsible for crafting
and constructing computer systems that
can process assess and produce humanlike
language NLP branches out into numerous
captivating domains including semantic
analysis sentiment analysis face
recognition machine translation and
speech recognition the reach of NLP
extends across a diverse spectrum of
applications notably featuring virtual
assistants chat boards sentiment
analysis customer service interactions
and natural language translation the
task of NLP Engineers involves erecting
these Innovative applications and
seamlessly embedding them into existing
Frameworks and now the average salary
for an NLP engineer is
$15,000 in the US and in India the
average annual salary for NLP Engineers
is 10 lakhs per an moving forward let's
see who owns more than NLP genium the
next is data scientist a data scientist
harness statistical and machine learning
methodologies to derive valuable
insights from extensive data sets their
duties Encompass formulating
experimental designs crafting predictive
models and conveying their Revelations
to relevant parties vital proficiency
involve adeptness in programming
languages like python NR a firm
grounding in statistics and a Mastery of
data visualization given the substantial
demand for their skills data scientist
command an average yearly salary of
$128,000 in us and in India average
yearly salary is 14 LS perom moving
forward let's see who wants more than AI
research scientist NLP engineer and data
scientist the next is machine learning
engineer a machine learning engineer
conceptualizes and constructs models and
Frameworks tailored for machine learning
purposes essential proficiencies andc
compass adeptness in programming
languages like python NR a grasp of
statistics and Mathematics and hands-on
experience in data manipulation their
dut is span handling substantial data
sets cooperating with vested parties and
Engineering Systems that are both
scalable and maintainable the average
annual income for machine learning
Engineers is
$140,000 in the US and in India it is 20
lakhs perom and the last we have deep
learning engineer deep learning
Engineers construct and formulate
intricate neural networks for tasks like
image recognition and natural language
processing profound familiarity with
deep learning Frameworks like tensor
flow and pytorch alongside adeptness in
programming languages such as python is
imperative Proficiency in advanced
mathematics and optimization techniques
is also indispensable their duties
Encompass the creation and training of
deep learning models defining model
efficiency and meticulous parameter
adjustment on average deep learning
Engineers earn an annual salary of
$158,000 in the US and in India average
annual salary is 25 lakhs perom it's
important to note that salaries can vary
significantly based on location and
other factors for instance job
opportunities and compensation are
higher in Tech hubs like Silicon Valley
New York City and other major tech
centers worldwide to get the most
upto-date information on salaries and
job Trends in the machine learning field
check job boards industry reports and
salary surveys specific to your region
and Industry also check our postgraduate
program in Ai and ml in partnership with
P University and in collaboration with
IBM to upskill yourself in this
thrilling field of machine learning and
don't forget to check the course link
from the description box below and with
that we have come to the end of this
session I hope you found it valuable and
entertaining please ask any questions
about the topics covered in this video
in the comment section below RX experts
will assist you in addressing your
problems thank you for watching stay
safe and keep learning staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here